well America didn't invade any countries
last year but one city still managed to
become a war zone unfortunately it was
within our borders Baltimore Maryland it
end of the year with 343 murders or 56
for every 100,000 people
that's the city's highest per capita
rate ever greater even than during the
Great crack epidemic the sad epidemic of
the 1980s there's one obvious culprit
for this as stand-down by police after
the 2015 riots they're following the
death of Freddie gray
Baltimore cops were pressured to back
off on tough policing tactics a lot of
them were afraid to go out and do what
they did before for the most part they
backed off and this is the result
Ladon Jones is a criminal defense
attorney and she joins us tonight thanks
for coming up thanks for having bats
like a happy new year a happy new year
so look there are people in Baltimore
who are you know not right wingers who
actually live there in contrast to a lot
of the leaders of black lives matter
rich kids on college campuses who are
saying that the police leaving has been
a tragedy this is the Reverend Kim G
Scott an activist in the city quote we
wanted the police there we wanted them
engaged in the community why wouldn't
people who live in a city with over 300
murders want police keeping order well
they absolutely do no one never said
that they didn't they want the same
thing that you talked about in your last
few segments they just don't want
government overreach by having police
officers who are abusive to innocent
people and abusing their power rather
than performing their role as law
enforcement well I think I mean I think
everybody wants that for sure and I
would I agree with him completely I hate
any abuse of power whether it's by the
cops or the DMV worker you deal with her
what any anybody abuse of power is
always wrong but that's not at all what
the black lives matter people in
Baltimore were saying I mean it was the
cops are the problem
the city's a bad place because of the
cops and then of course there were
threats of violence against the police
so if you're a Baltimore police officer
why would you even bother to put your
reputation or your life on the line to
help people well you know I understand
your argument as a public servant when
you
when you have a thankless job it's very
hard to get up the next day and do what
you need to do but that's what you
signed up for I don't think that the
black lives matter stands and last time
I was on your show you list me as a
black lives matter activist I'm not an
activist but I do understand their issue
they don't want government overreach by
too much force by the police and that's
what they said but that's not what
people heard people heard we don't want
the police well really they said we
don't want the police to kill us which
is a pretty different thing so the whole
like pigs-in-a-blanket murder cop stuff
that that was the nuance the message
that you're describing well I wouldn't
think it is any more fair than to put
all people who have this kind of
negative and divisive connotation as for
the whole city of Baltimore or the
entire black last matter even any more
fair than it would be to say that every
white person is with the Ku Klux Klan or
a neo-nazi that's not the case right
that was a that was out of black lives
matter March so I mean it's not it's not
like some out of nowhere connection that
was a day March and it's on video so
it's not like I'm making it up as you
well know it in every movement there are
detractors there are people who try to
take away from the real change and be
divisive there are people who are
mislead we've seen that in every single
movement that there was black lives
matter is no different but anyone who
really looks at what they stand for what
they put out what their leaders expose
is really getting to the 21st century
policing and making sure there's no
government overreach with all of them
keep using that phrase I mean I I doubt
that you're against any kind of
government over except this one but with
that let's just stick to this topic 2017
343 murders in the city of Baltimore why
is that well I don't live in Baltimore I
live in Atlanta but I can tell you as a
former prosecutor there are a number of
factors that go into the increase of
criminal activity but one of the number
one things the things that black lives
matter ask and many others is that we
want to make sure that the police are
involved and an integral part of the
community not against the community and
they have not read hold on I'm confused
so you say that you're part of black
lives matter at least sympathetic to it
so it's in the name black lives matter I
don't know what percentage of those - I
didn't say that yeah okay
I don't know what percentage of those
murder victims are african-american the
overwhelming majority
so I'm a little concerned and confused
by why you wouldn't have a better answer
than there are a lot of reasons like
it's a serious question why were 342
people murdered in Baltimore this year
have you thought about why absolutely
but I don't understand what one argument
has to do with the other there are a
number of reasons why there were murders
of black lives and all black lives all
lives do in fact matter and so whether
they're taken by the hands of the police
or if criminals I think people who
really care about the community want to
address both of those it doesn't have to
be either/or it's a lot of look black
lives matter spends all of his time
talking about how the cops are the
problem but I don't hear anybody even
thinking through like why is this
happening that's a lot of people to die
in a small city and I never hear anybody
say why Tucker I have a hard time
believing that you really have a whole
lot of conversations with black lives
matter to know what they all have known
about how they get reelected I can't get
a straight answer which is a little bit
revealing I will say that's exactly what
I just told you when we came on I'm not
a black lives matter activist but I do
oh but you have all Americans I would
hope that you would have to all
Americans should think about this issue
and we're actually saying this one who's
shown a difference I want to I want to
get a real answer but I'm not getting
one and that's thing that's there what
was the question thanks for joining us I
appreciate it